4 terriens de choix avec nous ce soir
fanny ardant
bernard bonsoir on se calme c'est donc
la première fois que je vous reçois dans
l'une de mes émissions j'en suis très
heureux alors avant de commencer est ce
qu'il ya des sujets que vous ne voulez
absolument pas abordée qu'on en parle
tout de suite quoi
non on verra au fil du temps l'accord
d'être comédienne actrice réalisatrice
vous êtes l'une des icônes du cinéma
français et vous n'aimez pas les
interviews à la télévision s'est
déclarée la télé anil la sincérité pas
de temps d' écoute tout le monde se
fiche de ce qui se dit c'est quand même
pas compliqué de venir à la télé pour
dire que votre film a été une
merveilleuse aventure humaine
est ce que ça a été une merveilleuse
aventure humaine oui voilà jusqu'ici ça
va à l'interview la veille tenait le
coup oui tu veux qu'on fasse une pause à
un moment
alors c'est la première fois que ni vous
faire interviewer par mois vous êtes dit
j'ai survécu à l'émission d'alessandra
sublet je peux bien léché hardy seront
faibles
on regarde ce qui s'est passé
spénard donc vous disait que le cinéma
était géniale pour ça qu'on rencontre
les acteurs on a des scènes à jouer avec
eux pas de méli mélo et en 15 secondes
il faut que ça se fasse c'est facile
quand il faut que ça soit cela se passe
pas comme ça on se pose pas la question
comme vous pouvez l'imposé la
réalisatrice a demandé d'être en jean
yahoo a vachement bien en plus mais il
paraît que c'est pas du tout votre truc
c'est vrai c'était pas très jean mais
j'ai passé ma vie un portrait d'une
jeune fille est sortie cette info on a
envie d'avoir 60 ans
qu'est ce qu'on fait à 60 qu'on fait pas
à 30 ou à 40 je pense pas qu'on puisse à
zoner par tranche d'âge je veux faire
désirer forcément dans ce métier c'est
aussi ce qui vous tient à coeur
j'imagine ça fait partie on trouvera du
cheminement quoi désiré où vous le
désirez
sourit on lui est encore meilleur
faut dire les choses c'est pas très bien
passé au départ des jalles vous avez
confondu avec catherine deneuve donc
c'est quand même très emmerdant après
faisait appeler stéphanie ardent et
quand on lui a parlé de truffaut à la
christine jardinerie donc
vous avez eu un gros succès en 2013 avec
les beaux jours de marion vernoux avec
laurent lafitte vous étiez tellement
sexy dans le film que le nouvel obs vous
a mis à la une en écrivant vous étiez
une sexy génère moi je ne trouve plus
sexy que ge energy
alors vous avez déclaré au sujet de
cette une le monde est à feu et à sang
on n'a rien d'autre à s'occuper c'est
terrible cette idée de définir les gens
par la rage et cette idée qu'il faut
rester sexy jusqu'à 90 ans vous êtes
sexy je peux par exemple
non parce que c'est souvent comment
rester sexy et si on n'avait pas envie
de rester sexy ouais c'est ça vous êtes
sexy
quoi
cette rigueur en fait que vous avez ça
vient de votre milieu d'origine en fait
vous êtes issu d'une vieille famille
limousine les ardents du pic vous êtes
né à saumur déjà ce million c'est le
cadre noir ça rigole pas votre père
était officier de cavalerie non vous a
élevé à la dure et non on n'est pas
élevé par un homme ou une femme qui ont
un métier on est élevé par un père et
une mère ouais et moi si j'ai connu
quelqu'un de libre et de fantaisiste et
d'humanisme ah ouais j'ai jacques rincon
dit un officier de cavalerie en sort une
petite cravacher avait bien sûr pas du
tout c'est pas le cas de pape a
alors votre père était précepteur et ami
du prince rainier il a été gouverneur du
palais il a fait une carrière militaire
qui l'a conduit partout dans le monde
vous habitez partout en fait oui partout
ça explique votre accent de nulle part
ça oui sûrement parce que chaque fois on
reste assez temps pour prendre
l'internation déjeuner puis fichiers la
main se fait un petit cocktail alors
après cendres et sang votre premier film
en tant que réalisatrice vous sortez le
8 janvier votre deuxième film en tant
que réalisatrice ça s'appelle cadence
obstiné avec asia argento et gérard
depardieu vous dites que l'idée vous en
est venu à cause d'une phrase de
marguerite duras très belle faut bien le
dire attendre l'amour c'est déjà de la
mort c'est génial
c'est bon
c'est à chier chanteuse gustin qui l'y
chercher dieu c'est déjà le trouver
voilà mais sauf que marguerite duras
c'est plutôt l'amour que dieu bravo
bravo
[Musique]
alors ce film c'est quatre danseuses
obstiné sont celles de la construction
d'un hôtel et de la déconstruction d'un
amour le moment de l'amour quand l'amour
s'en va ouais et les attentes justement
comment retrouver la fulgurance des
débuts comment retrouver la magie
est ce qu'on va tout détruire plutôt que
de s'habituer à la tiédeur et à la
monotonie ou est ce qu'il faudrait
plutôt pactiser avec l'ennemi entre
guillemets comme la vie et moi c'est la
première fois que je conçois mais je
regrette j'aurais dû vous recevoir je
suis fascinée d'abus je dis rien
vraiment alors deux choses d'abord
graphiquement c'est magnifique tiens
l'image est sublime un très grand chef
la deuxième chose c'est quasi argent
tout elle joue un petit peu votre rôle
fois on vous l'avait demandé un moment
de se mettre sur des talons vous saviez
pas s'il allait accepter je disais ce
attendu d'avoir des talons maquet
après ça tu en huile de très maquillée
n'ont donc qu'elle a été un elle a tout
donné un genre est passé faire un petit
coucou pour même prix c'est sympa très
qu'est ce qui lui a pris la de partir
comme ça non mais vous qui le connaissez
non mais moi je pense que s'il ya une
liberté qui appartient à l'homme c'est
de pouvoir habiter où ils vont
donc aller par mon vieux va où tu veux
et pas tout le monde qui reste sur son
perchoir a donné des notes hallucinant
avec vous pardon à tirer c'est que vous
pourriez dire je voudrais manger deux
pommes la manière dont vous le dites
mais c'est cette pomme toute saveur tout
à fait particulier
c'est bon
vous pourriez pas nous dire vous avez
envie d'une pomme
non mais du chocolat mais qu'est ce
qu'on va faire ça va être horrible on va
faire une interview alerte aux roses
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte
et chomedey ah oui quel endroit vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour
dans une mosquée
tu l'as d'or toi un fanny ardant
le sais je l'aï déjà dit ce que vous
préférez un homme qui fait bien l'amour
mais qui est moche ou un homme qui fait
mal d'amour mais qui est très beau le
premier mode bombe a une chance
préféré larguer ou faire larguer
me faire larguer je préfère être pas
celle qui a occasionné la douleur
préféré oric votre homme vous quitte
pour un homme pour une femme pour une
femme
préféré être caressé par quelqu'un qui
vous répugne ou battu par quelqu'un qui
vous aiment
bien
battu mais avec possibilité de répondre
à
le moment idéal de la journée pour faire
un bon c'est quoi
c'est celui qu'on attendait pas
alors dernière question si vous deviez
en choisir une avec laquelle des
personnes ici présentes sur diego
l'amour non non non non
merci de votre patience
moi je sais
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu